Boris Johnson facing a bruising
cross-examination by MPS at party Gates
this afternoon before that starts at 2PM
let's speak to a conservative MP Peter
bone a long-standing defender of the
former PM throughout party gate where
there's no hi good morning good morning
always great to see you thanks for
joining us on the program is he fighting
for his political life today not really
I mean what it is is a part of the
process of the Privileges committee he
will present he's already presented his
evidence which is pretty strong in his
favor and he'll answer the question for
quite a considerable amount of time
today which I'm sure everyone will be
interested in then the committee will go
away mull over these things and reach a
decision if the committee decides that
he should be suspended and he's
suspended for 10 days or more he could
face a by-election well that's not quite
right the committee can only recommend
to Parliament than the whole of the
House of Commons votes and whatever that
was my shorthand but that's what I
should say and I mean I don't think for
one moment they're going to reach that
decision because if you look at
objectively to say that Boris Johnson
knowingly lied to Parliament doesn't he
fled well known misled light is the same
thing isn't it it's just there's no
evidence of it I mean haven't they had
thousands and thousands of WhatsApp
messages and they've been going on for
this inquiry for 10 months and found
nothing that's not quite what the part
the committee is saying they've released
their preliminary findings ahead of Mr
Johnson appearing before them as you
know and it would suggest that they
don't think that that's the case and he
very much has a case to answer well I
don't I don't think they've reached a
conclusion uh I'm pretty I'm sure they
haven't received yeah well I'm very
pedantic this morning if you had three
sure did wait well you know getting up
early and the excitement of coming on
your program I did have my breakfast
before coming I'm glad to hear it I I'm
sure that Boris Johnson will need a good
breakfast before he gets him probably
asleep for us at the moment as well but
you know he they do think he has a case
to answer which is why he's up in front
of us well this is this is the primary
face here thing about well it might be a
case so you look at there's an inquiry
and it's sort of based on the Sue gray
investigation we now know that Sue gray
is what going to be Chief of Staff to
Kirsten and they were having discussions
while the while the investigation was
going no they weren't they were having
him now who's been
she was having discussions with them in
during the committee investigation not
during her actual investigation I'm glad
you corrected me not at all but you
wouldn't you you will I mean if they are
calling Witnesses presumably Sue gray
would be called and she is now
um
very closely involved with the leader
labor party which must I mean I don't
think in a quarter law that would be
allowed to be clearly a conflict of
interest but so many of your colleagues
sat there over the previous month during
the investigation saying we must wait
for the Sue gray inquiry because she is
a very independent civil servant and we
didn't know at that time well I I've
said it as I said in House of Commons I
think the fact that the senior civil
sermon has gone straight from that role
to being a senior advisors leader of
labor party throws a coats and horses
through our civil service be careful
because of course you're not protected
by parliamentary privileges out there
what are you suggesting are you
suggesting that she is biased towards a
labor party and so she came up with
those conclusions no what I'm saying and
I said in the House of Commons you know
we have this tradition of the Civil
Service being there to advise people of
any political persuasion and they don't
then go and join a political party
um and that's what is strange and it
breaks with the tradition and it's it's
more like when moving towards the
American system where you point people
who believe in what you do and then when
you leave you change them it's a big
question from the Civil Service what
was going through Boris Johnson's mind
then when he was eating cake on his
birthday and was raising a glass of wine
in photographs that we've seen and was
aware of at least 14 events that were
taking part in dining Street and was
also fined by the Metropolitan Police
well if you need I mean the only event
that um he got fined for was the the
cake in the when he was having a work
meeting and somebody turned up as a
surprise piece of cake which by the way
was published at the time in fact it was
in the Times newspaper nobody thought
anything of it it wasn't pre-planned by
Boris and all so none of the other so
why did he accept that he'd broken the
rules well because the police found him
guilty of doing it
but that was that was the only event
wasn't he didn't have to accept that
fine did he he could have challenged it
in court he chose not to well I'm sure
he could have done but the the point is
you're saying he was at all lots of
these different uh what you'd call
parties but he wasn't no no I was saying
it was at 14 separate events and that's
what he will have to be answering what
did he think they were the work meetings
yeah and you do you often have wine at
work meetings I I don't drink okay well
that's that's do you I mean I look
pleasure I mean as a business meeting do
you occasionally have a drinks with it
we don't tend to no we don't know
we don't have it on occasion on the
premises
yeah well exactly so we certainly do
then
um we'll have to wait and see what
happens as far as whether the committee
believe him today it is four
conservatives uh the head of the
committee the chairperson of course is
labor and then we have SMP and lib Dem
as well the only thing I'd say about the
committee and I'm a great fan of
parliamentary committees is I'm very
surprised that when the previous Germans
stood down because he'd prejudged it
Chris Brighton the right to stand down
the replacement was a former interim
leader of the labor party twice interim
leader labor party had already
prejudiced the matter I thought that I
advised as well well I'm just saying
it's strange isn't it I could have
thought of a lot of Labor MPS who hadn't
prejudged it who could have um been
chairman
are you saying she's biased uh I I'm not
saying I'm just saying it's unusual okay
as long as you're not saying it's biased
because obviously they would have
something to say about that let me talk
quickly about the vote today Northern
Ireland protocol Boris Johnson says he
is going to vote against it what are you
going to do well we were promised
there's one particular aspect yes that's
the point you're making yeah we were
promised a full debate on the Windsor
framework and and we would have a whole
day debate and then we'd vote on it
while we're actually being asked in 90
minutes is to vote on one specific break
which is then apparently going to be
um our vote on the whole frame now if I
get a question of pmqs I'm going to ask
the Prime Minister what happened to our
why to vote so I'm really pretty miffed
that they are avoiding uh the
government's avoiding
um scrutiny on this and uh on the break
itself it seems to
um fail all the tests in fact it's
supposed to be worse than useless so if
that is the case I'm going to listen to
the debate I'm going to go to meetings
this morning
um but my if I had to vote at this
moment of time I should vote against
let's switch and see um let's see if you
get a question a pmq is if you do you'll
be on the Telly because we're covering
it live from noon thank you very much
indeed for joining us always